hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lines okay I think
we're approaching the amphitheater that
come from here today they come in here
or out of here okay let's go
so this must be the door damage I'd I'm
thinking I'm getting close at the end or
maybe now maybe there's ten billion
other levels who knows really dark dank
dirty she's quite whoa now this is
interesting
Wow once again the guy coming up with a
unique and interesting level design wow
that is cool
kudos to this guy I mean his the
imagination is great drives a great game
is really cool
just look at it looks like the pit into
hell
which I guess is the idea the more
unique music - very very cool
alright we're still going after C man
for some reason
C man was a game on the Dreamcast that I
played I raised him from a little bitty
egg all the way to an a grown adult that
could talk yeah you could talk to your C
man this is penumbra all these are
penumbra textures maybe there's a lot
more than I thought there was whoa hey
light what are you doing
stop that holy crap yeah these are these
are penumbra textures
maybe there's way more than I thought
there was mmm interesting yep this is
penumbra it's all about the penumbra
this looks rickety the number trashcan
the number of dog sounds in the
background I guess it would be easy to
import them there on the same won't cut
the same exact engine but the same
similar engines yeah was blocking that
door
nothing oh look it's a penumbra cabinet
oh let's open number a computer I can't
click on it
it's an amnesia furnace there we go we
realized the nightmare from the Power
Core everything everyone got a nightmare
some even got killed strange enough one
guy named David that guy he didn't got
any nightmares we trying to kill him why
because he was trying to stop us from
releasing the realizing realizing the
power of the core power ok thanks for
explaining why anyway our safe is begin
to collapse we had to add wooden poles
to keep the ceiling intact ok project
David that means hello
ooh number electronics pin number chair
I'll open numbers here you are useful
you were sturdy and powerful yeah yeah
whoo another pin number chair oh I can't
use you traitor
aah all right we're coming through I
said we're coming through yeah got it
through that door opening I guess these
are the wooden poles to that safe
don't know what that's all about but it
is really cool that they're using
different stuff I mean he'll use all the
stuff you can to make um make the level
more interesting I mean why not all adds
to the experience okay
that's nothing some beeped
that's collapsed all right okay there
was only one way to go then fine Oh me
shut up don't cares big whiny baby big
whiny baby Oh No
I hope they don't bring back the number
of spiders I hate the but number of
spiders
I know for the newcomers the safe is
made in 1986 the comments comment number
one already at the first day we felt
something strange like breathing in our
necks not on our necks in our next
comment number two many people fainted
randomly some of them got a terrible
nightmare or no note by accessing secure
doors asks the administrator for
permission to unlock the secure doors by
using the computer to unlock doors oh
man this grammar is starting to get to
me these were penumbra pill bottles they
were supposed to give health back I
guess he's not doing that now
administrator in middle strata where do
I go I this is like all there was Oh
Fleck
bonk got it must have been those doors
over there
come on chair we got this anybody want
to mess with us
keep hearing noises in the background
you guys would let me know if there's
like some diabolical creature creeping
up behind me you would well ha yeah I
see them yeah I saw them okay what the
hell are you looking at it's moving my
camera for me my chair
oh my shirt Oh chair are you okay what
do you want
douchebags alright these guys hello oh
you want me to go this way oh no kill
the darkness destroy the power source
and free us all I would think that the
darkness would be able to you know grow
if I turned off all the power can't
answer the phone right now so uh whoa
hello alright then okay so did the door
open now
maybe yes there it is cherry you okay
all you made it you survived good for
you
I never doubted you for a second hello
well it's my chair
oh hi you know if it crashes I'd usually
think the whole light would go out but
whatever you do your thing
don't let me say anything about it well
it's in here in the unbelievably dark
darkness a TV or chair again hello and
part-time right around chair whoa dead
guy come here dead guy's gone what's so
scary
ah
I need something to open them how about
a chair ha ha ha ha ok switch here Chuck
yeah yeah
yeah it's better really well done
nice okay come on thank you you are so
useful see no one can doubt the power of
a chair
come come Oh what hey I wasn't done with
that level all right there was so much
more to explore maybe there's something
else I hope I didn't miss something okay
that wasn't scary
Oh anybody oh no I thought it was gonna
be like the thing where you like in
penumbra where you had to walk through
the light as they turn on but they just
try to darkness
what does darkness ever scared me never
never
yeah I actually used to be kind of
afraid of the dark but ever since I
started playing horror games I kind of
lost that fear I know anybody Erin how
about it
[Music]
no no no no nope nope waste of time
really oh man
really are you kidding me oh wow that
was ridiculous hi Billy Mays here I
don't even think these guys taking
himself seriously all right whatever
that's fine with me all right
two locked doors I'm sure I got enough
I got large I'm good to go
as the Dickens
that is hilarious
blood leads behind this door this can't
be good no of course it can this is an
amnesia box on a penumbra box box
ception
man I'm really wondering if I missed
something in that other room I guess I
could go back yeah I must have missed
something because everything here is
locked so I got to go back there get
something to get this and I'll be fine
it's dark good show dark door dork dodge
the doors Doge Doge click click click
click click click come on really you
seriously suggesting that I'm trapped
here there's nothing to do nothing to be
done really like that fine something pot
break my ish maybe oh maybe I have a
tool to open this door here on me like
this weird powers fair hammer chisel
ooh Rock rocking it's a big old rock
maybe I need to throw something at the
door and it seems logical to me their
box
throw a fight a rock if I could get that
rock out I'd throw a rock at it with
whatever hop owner but ever do I do
anything huh yeah yeah yeah I see jiggle
come on I can get it I've broken doors
before usually with chairs but no boxes
okay so I don't know what I'm supposed
to do like seriously Ivy both these
doors on the other side are locked
is there anything in these trash cans
that maybe I get I don't know I feel
like maybe I wasn't supposed to come
here this soon
OOP my fail
anybody rock your body man there's
literally nothing
hmm damn it I hope I don't have to like
low to save or something
no it's ah there's nothing here I can't
do anything all these doors are locked
and there was nothing in any of those
rooms all right maybe maybe there was
like a key or something and I have to
look a little closer I did conscious
glance so I'll look again but there
better be someone there
anything under the bed look like it
just
No
under the table
there's nothing in here on the floor on
the ceiling no bucket no nothing in that
room nothing under there anything under
here nope on the Brady or bucket
probably like the chamber pot you don't
know how chamber pot is look it up
anything under the bed no hide myself in
the closet some weird nightmare I'll pop
up no there nothing behind there here ah
damn it damn it I might just be stuck
because I went ahead without before
dammit
alright huh
yeah actually now that I've got a rock
let me try one last thing before I love
to say try to use this rock on that door
well because why else would there be a
rock in that trash can unless they
wanted me to use a rock no yeah so the
rock ain't no trash can yeah that did it
okay look I might have to load another
Saviour all right
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode thanks again everybody so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
bye-bye